so when the market gets tough what do
people need they need good sales people
so you get the BD directors right you
get the best ones in the market ideally
we're getting on the phone with the
client and pitching them in right I'm
calling them saying look three of your
competitors are interviewing this BD
candid they're the best person on the
market they're the number one person in
California the revenue they've done in
the last three years is 10 million 20
million 30 million can you really afford
to let them join your biggest competitor
surely it's worth you speaking to them I
don't understand how anyone would ever
say no to that look they're interviewing
me fre boost competitors they want to
join you they're actively looking
they're going to be gone in two weeks
like at least have a trap with them and
that's your door opener so